you may qualify to get Eargo at
no cost to you.
AINSLEY: ONE U.S. SENATOR
SHINING A LIGHT ON STATEWIDE
HYPOCRISY.
STEVE: OUR NEXT GUEST’S PROPOSED
BILL WOULD REQUIRE ANY STATE
IMPLEMENTING VACCINE PASSPORTS
TO ALSO MANDATE VOTER ID.
BRIAN: NORTH DAKOTA SENATOR
KEVIN CLAIMER JOINING US --
KRAMER JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
>> SEEMS PRETTY OBVIOUS TO ME,
BRIAN.
I NEVER CEASE TO BE AMAZED AT
HOW EASILY DEMOCRATS WILLING TO
GIVE UP THEIR PERSONAL PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE RECORDS JUST TO EAT
AT A RESTAURANT IN MANHATTAN BUT
THEN TO DO SOMETHING AS
IMPORTANT AS CASTING A VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
SO WHAT MY BILL INTENDS TO DO IS
SHINE THAT SPOTLIGHT OF
HYPOCRISY -- WHICH, BY THE WAY,
THAT’S NOT EXACTLY NEW IN
POLITICS, BUT THIS IS A PRETTY
EXTREME VERSION OF IT.
AINSLEY: THIS IS REALLY A
MESSAGE FOR BILL DE BLASIO,
BECAUSE WE’RE THE FIRST CITY IN
THE COUNTRY THAT IS SAYING YOU
HAVE TO SHOW A VACCINE PASSPORT
IN ORDER TO EAT INDOORS, GO TO A
GYM, GO TO A SHOW.
ARE WE GOING TO NOW SHOW AN ID
WHEN WE VOTE HERE?
>> I HAVEN’T HEARD FROM BILL DE
BLASIO, AND I EXPECT THAT WE
WON’T, BUT HE’S GOING TO HAVE TO
ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
GROSS INTRUSION ON PEOPLE’S
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
AND I THINK THIS IS REALLY, TO
ME, A FRIGHTENING SITUATION
WHERE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
DEMONSTRATE OR PROVE THAT, YOU
KNOW, A VACCINATION.
THAT IS HIGHLY PERSONAL AND
PRIVATE INFORMATION.
STEVE: RIGHT.
AND, OF COURSE, SENATOR, IT’S
ALL ABOUT THEY’RE TRYING TO
GET -- RIGHT NOW I THINK THE
NUMBER IS JUST UNDER 50%, JUST
UNDER 50% OF AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
IMMUNIZED AGAINST COVID.
THE ADMINISTRATION REALIZES TO
GET TO HERD IMMUNITY THESE DAYS,
YOU’VE GOT TO BE AT 70, 80, 85%.
THE NUMBER SEEMS TO BE CHANGING.
SO THEIR JUST TRYING -- THEY’RE
JUST TRYING, THEY’RE PULLING OUT
ALL THE STOPS TRYING TO GET
EVERYBODY VACCINATED.
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS, STEVE.
FIRST OF ALL, THERE’S BEEN NO
CREDIT GIVEN TO THE FACT THAT
MANY PEOPLE HAVE, YOU KNOW,
ANTIBODIES BECAUSE THEY’VE HAD
THE DISEASE ITSELF --
STEVE: THAT’S RIGHT.
>> THE OTHER IS IT’S
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT
ILL-INFORMED ABOUT THIS.
THERE’S LOTS OF INFORMATION.
SELF-GOVERNED PEOPLE ARE CAPABLE
OF -- AND WHEN YOU START
BULLYING OR HARASSING PEOPLE,
THAT’S VERY COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
LET PEOPLE CONSULT THEIR
DOCTORS, MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS.
BRIAN: WHAT’S GOING ON WITH THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL?
2,702 PAGES, THEY NEED 10
REPUBLICANS TO VOTE FOR IT.
IT IS GOING TO ADD TO THE
DEFICIT, IT IS NOT PAID FOR,
IT’S GOING TO BE $A 256
BILLION -- $256 BILLION
ACCORDING TO THE CBO.
HOW TO YOU STAND, SENATORSOME.
>> I SUPPORT IT FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS.
FIRST OF ALL, THE CBO SCORE IS
NOT THE ONLY THING THAT MATTERS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PAY-FORS.
CBO IS BARRED FROM INCLUDING
REPURPOSING ALREADY APPROPRIATED
FUNDS FROM THE CARES ACT AND
OTHER, YOU KNOW, RELIEF
PACKAGES.
SO IS IT ACTUALLY, IN MY VIEW,
I’M VERY COMFORTABLE WITH THE
PAY-FORS.
BUT BEYOND THAT, EVEN IF IT’S
$25 BILLION A YEAR OF EXPENSE,
WE’VE JUST SPENT $7 TRILLION ON
THINGS THAT PRODUCED NOTHING
NOW -- DON’T GET ME WRONG -- TO
PEOPLE’S INDIVIDUAL ECONOMIES.
BUT AN ASSET LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE
HAS AS ITS PRIMARY PURPOSE THE
MOVEMENT OF GOODS AND SERVICES
IN OUR ECONOMY, IT’S AN ASSET
THAT RETURNS VALUE TO OUR
ECONOMY AND, ULTIMATELY, TO THE
TAXPAYERS.
IS SO I STILL THINK THIS IS A
VERY GOOD AND, I THINK, A HIGH
PRIORITY AND IMPORTANT --
BRIAN: DOES IT PASS THE SENATE
TODAY?
>> I BELIEVE IT’LL PASS IF NOT
TODAY, TOMORROW.
YOU MENTIONED SENATOR HAGERTY’S
OBJECTION TO MOVING QUICKLY
THROUGH THE AMENDMENTS.
HE HAS EVERY RIGHT TO DO THAT.
IF IT TAKES A DAY LONGER, THEN
WE STAY HERE AND GET IT DONE
TOMORROW NIGHT IF WE CAN’T GET